so we're following the growing story of
Donald Trump allegedly withholding 250
million dollars in military aid from
Ukraine because Ukraine appears not to
have followed through with Donald
Trump's request that they investigate
and smear Joe Biden for the benefit of
Trump in 2020 which in and of itself is
a massive scandal and what we now have
our videos of both Rudy Giuliani and
Donald Trump being asked about this
we'll start with Giuliani will go to
Trump a little bit later on so Rudy
Giuliani has invited onto CNN with Chris
Cuomo and within it this is within a one
minute segment but the contradiction
actually happens within about 25 seconds
Rudy Giuliani first denies and then
immediately admits to asking Ukraine to
investigate Joe Biden so as you probably
are familiar with at this point every
time something like this happens
initially there's just a blanket denial
from trumpets and even even though very
often the Trump administration will not
formally make a denial but then
individual elements start to be
acquiesced to Rudy Giuliani here and
Donald Trump later so this is all the
same one-minute clip Rudy Giuliani
denies that they did this then says the
opposite and admits that of course they
did need to investigate Joe Biden no
actually I didn't I asked the Ukraine to
investigate the allegations that there
was interference in the election of 2016
by the Ukrainians for the benefit of
Hillary Clinton for which they were
already ISM never ending anything about
hunter Biden you never asked anything
about Joe by the only thing I asked
about Joe Biden is to get to the bottom
of how it was that would Senko who was
appointed right dismissed the case
against until you did ask Ukraine to
look into Joe Biden of course I did you
just said you didn't know I didn't ask
him to look into Joe Biden I asked me
wasn't the allegations that related to
my client which tangentially involved
Joe Biden in a massive bribery spooty
not unlike what he did in China Rudy you
explained to me how the kid got 1.5
billion dollars I have no
personalizations but just be careful
about what you say I
I'm Harry crane look at Joe Biden you
said no then you went on to say that you
did no I didn't say or did what I said
was this I asked them to investigate the
allegations that relate to the false
charges against the president United
States those allegations tangentially
involved Biden should have let me finish
Chris let me finish I didn't ask you
crane anything about Biden other than of
course I asked them about these three
things related to Joe Biden it's getting
to be that crisp season here in New
England that comes after the summer
which we call the season for treason and
lies anytime that Rudy Giuliani is
involved and it's actually even worse
than Rudy Giuliani just denying and then
admitting this Rudy Giuliani in that
clip denies it then admits it and
immediately denies having denied it just
25 seconds before and the the saddest
and the most tragic part of this all is
that this is convincing too many
trumpets there are trumpets who hear the
allegations and of course they're primed
with quote fake news as a meme they
immediately are primed to say this must
be fake this must not be real and they
start clawing around the internet
desperately looking for some way out of
a room that has no exits quite frankly
they want some defense they want some
clarification so then Rudy Giuliani goes
on CNN and says oh I never did it
followed by of course I did it followed
by I never denied doing it even though
he just denied doing it 25 seconds
earlier and Trump Asiya and they say
David David David this didn't you see
Rudy Giuliani on Chris Cuomo he already
explained this entire thing he did a
great job see Rudy cleared it all up
it's just another one of these fake news
smears and unfortunately we were working
actually on a long-form piece about what
I call the knowledge pyramid which is
that you have all these people
commenting on the top of the knowledge
pyramid which is day to day news with no
knowledge foundation
they lack all knowledge of epistemology
and critical thinking and news literacy
media literacy and subject matter
knowledge so they just appear and they
see what's at the top of the pyramid the
sort of junk food the day-to-day
occurrences which out of context don't
really tell you anything and that's how
you end up bamboozled into thinking hey
look Rudy already cleared this up
there's absolutely nothing here
so that's Rudy Giuliani's commentary
denial acceptance and then a denial of
the denial that just happened let's next
talk about Donald Trump being asked
about all of this